[Música]
ah
la primera vez que volví a casa desde
que empecé a trabajar en guinea bissau
era casi navidad estaba súper emocionada
con aquello con volver a casa y con
hacer todas las cosas que había echado
de menos irme a tomar unas cañas irme de
compras ver a mi gente hasta echarme una
siesta con un edredón nórdico tapadita
hasta aquí
estaba súper emocionada y con todo el
subidón fui a casa de mis padres aquí en
segovia y al abrir la nevera y ver todos
aquellos productos típicos de la época
me puse a llegar
era la primera vez que yo me enfrentaba
de forma tan cruda y tan dura a mis
privilegios y a como tener la nevera
llena poco o nada tiene que ver con tu
esfuerzo o con tu fuerza de voluntad y
muchísimo con el sitio en el que hayas
caído al nacer
bueno me podréis decir clara a ver no
hace falta irse a áfrica para darse
cuenta de esto simplemente con encender
la tele nos damos cuenta de cómo está el
mundo verdad la cantidad de desgracias
que vemos ahí fuera cada vez hay más
guerra hambre injusticia social
violencia de género
cuántas veces nos sentimos abrumados y
abrumadas y necesitamos cambiar de canal
pasar o tirar el periódico y cerrar
nuestras redes sociales
yo lo comparo a como si nos hubieran
picado mil mosquitos a la vez y sólo
tuviéramos una oportunidad de rascar nos
y con el bloqueo no nos rascas hemos
nada al final y es que no es bastante
fuerte que a día de hoy estén sucediendo
de manera simultánea en dos sitios
distintos del mundo cosas como estas por
un lado hay un coche que conduce solo
solo sin necesidad de conductor hemos
sido capaces de desarrollar la
tecnología y la aplicación que hace
posible que el coche conduzca solo pero
a la vez y por otro lado cada minuto
muere un niño de hambre
no es increíble
además las personas que confiamos y que
queremos un mundo mejor y que creemos en
ello no nos conformamos con el sentido
tradicional de caridad lo típico me
encuentro un pobre a la puerta de un
supermercado le he hecho una moneda y me
voy a mi casa tan tranquila porque
porque esto no cambia las cosas en
absoluto el pobre va a seguir siendo
pobre y tú no has hecho ningún esfuerzo
porque esa moneda no significa
absolutamente nada para ti
además no todo el mundo se puede
permitir apoyar económicamente a una ong
dedicarse profesionalmente a la
cooperación al desarrollo oa la ayuda de
emergencia ni ser por supuesto
accionista principal de una gran
multinacional para poder cambiar las
cosas y las decisiones a nivel mundial
bueno pues aún habiendo contado esto
yo estoy aquí hoy para deciros que
podéis cambiar el mundo si todas las
personas que están aquí a través de
vuestro poder individual a través de las
decisiones que tomas todos los días y os
voy a proponer un sistema muy sencillo
de tres pasos que son yo en el mundo
yo en mi ciudad y yo cuestionándome para
explicaros cómo podéis hacerlo no voy a
hablaros de acciones colectivas como
votar
nuestro poder como consumidoras o formar
parte de organizaciones de la sociedad
civil sino de cosas muy sencillas
cotidianas que podemos hacer todos los
días y que vais a poder adaptar según
vuestro contexto de influencia pues bien
en el centro de este sistema de tres
pasos
hay un concepto clave que os voy a
explicar
con un juego de cartas
el juego consiste
en que me va a tocar una carta de todo
este montón tengo que elegir una al azar
vale bueno vamos a ver si tengo suerte
voy a barajar
[Música]
ay qué nervios de verdad qué pasará
que me va a tocar la cojo ya no venga
voy a cortar venga la de aquí arriba o
la de abajo
venga voy a está
no la miro
sabéis lo que me ha salido
qué alivio me ha salido mujer
de clase media-alta en españa en el
siglo 21
menos mal os imagináis que me hubiera
salido un niño rojin ya en mi alma
o una persona mayor enferma en un gueto
en nueva york
y si me hubiera salido un adolescente en
sudán del sur porque es que hay que ver
lo que es la suerte verdad pues bien esa
suerte que acabamos de ver es en
realidad el concepto del privilegio
un privilegio es una situación ventajosa
que nos viene dada en general desde la
cuna y no hemos hecho nada en absoluto
para merecerla
los privilegios son en general
invisibles pero están muy presentes en
nuestras vidas porque en torno a ellos
se articula todo el poder toda la
representación toda la ciudadanía de los
sistemas que habitamos
en el centro de esos privilegios nos
encontramos al hombre blanco
heterosexual de clase media de un país
rico
si queremos afinar más en concreto este
detalle de ese centro de los privilegios
nos tenemos que preguntar a quien en mi
contexto no se me permite criticar y
esto nos va a dar una idea un poco mejor
de cómo afinar ese centro de los
privilegios
qué pasa con este centro de los
privilegios cuanto más nos alejemos de
él más difíciles tendremos el disfrute
de nuestros derechos para decirlo de
otra manera más puertas tendremos que
abrir para poder gozar de una ciudadanía
plena
vamos a ver ahora con algunos ejemplos
cómo podemos identificar esos
privilegios
que tenemos a nuestro alrededor con
respecto a la gente que está a nuestro
alrededor el primero de los ejemplos mi
vecino está en el paro nos llegan a fin
de mes
nadie me contrata porque tiene una
discapacidad
y tú sí que llegas a fin de mes entonces
no solamente es que él tenga un problema
es que tú también tienes un privilegio
a mi hermana le encanta salir por la
noche
con lo que se oye últimamente le da
mucho miedo volver a casa
cada vez hay más casos de violaciones
acoso callejero tú cuando sales ni te
planteas eso nunca lo ha sufrido en sus
propias carnes a lo mejor entonces es
que tienes también un privilegio el otro
día de portaban a un africano
en el avión en el que yo viajaba
y le reportaban a un país cercano al
suyo ni siquiera su propio país cuál era
su delito no tener la situación
administrativa en regla
os suena vosotros nunca os habéis
planteado esto sois nacionales del país
en el que vivís tenéis los documentos en
regla entonces es que también tenéis un
privilegio vale sí clara genial tengo
miles de privilegios y qué hago ahora me
siento fatal me tengo que sentir mal por
comer todos los días
tener trabajo techo no al contrario
vamos a utilizar esa consciencia que
acabamos de adquirir para intentar
cambiar el mundo para cambiar ese
desequilibrio que encontramos con
nuestro vecino que además va a afectar a
escala global a como suceden las cosas a
nivel de desequilibrios mundiales con
este sistema de tres pasos yo en el
mundo
yo en mi ciudad pueblo o barrio y yo
cuestionándome empezamos por el primero
yo en el mundo como me doy cuenta de los
privilegios que tengo con respecto a la
población mundial simplemente me tengo
que plantear la siguiente pregunta quién
sería yo si en lugar de haber nacido
aquí lo hubiera hecho unos kilómetros al
norte al sur al este o al oeste en el
país vecino habría sufrido la guerra
me habrían torturado se habrían
apropiado ilegalmente de mis tierras y
mis casas vulneraría mis derechos por mi
género
el segundo paso yo en mi ciudad en mi
contexto en mi barrio
vamos a ver cuáles son esos privilegios
que tenemos con respecto a nuestros
vecinos con una pregunta de nuevo
sencilla quién sería yo si en lugar de
haber nacido en este cuerpo lo hubiera
hecho en el cuerpo de una mujer trans
en el de un niño que llega en patera o
en el de una persona con discapacidad
por último el tercero de los pasos vamos
a utilizar los privilegios que
identifiquemos con los dos anteriores
para renunciar a ellos de manera
proactiva y poder aportar nuestro
granito de arena para un mundo mejor
porque a menudo las personas que están
sentadas en su sillón de los privilegios
no se dan cuenta de que la mayoría de
las cosas que hacen no las hacen porque
quieren no las hacen porque pueden
que para que podamos comprarnos una
camiseta a tres euros hay una niña en
bangladesh que no va a la escuela y que
está explotada laboralmente que para que
el norte tenga la última tecnología el
congo se desangra o que para que
nosotras podemos y podamos votar decidir
libremente sobre el aborto y nuestros
cuerpos y algo tan sencillo como abrir
una cuenta solas
hubo una feminista que se dejó aquí la
piel
muy bien vamos a ver ahora algunos
ejemplos concretos de cómo utilizar
estos pasos de acuerdo empezamos por el
principio
las mujeres sufrimos dobles y triples
jornadas de trabajo según naciones
unidas por el mismo trabajo una mujer
recibe un euro perdón a un hombre recibe
un euro y una mujer 77 céntimos además
nos ocupamos un 2,5 más de los cuidados
que nuestros compañeros varones y el 35%
recordad la cifra 35 por ciento de las
mujeres de todo el mundo incluyendo los
países del norte han sufrido sufren o
sufrirán violencia física o sexual por
parte de sus compañeros las personas que
supuestamente más deberían querer las
qué podemos hacer ahora a nivel
individual
para equilibrar estos datos bien cuál es
tu privilegio eres el hijo mayor de una
mujer tradicional española y vas a cenar
a casa de tus padres en nochebuena tu
madre se encarga de la cena acabásemos
qué puedes hacer ahora que te das cuenta
porque además ni lo piensas ni sabes
cuánta gente va a cenar ni lo preparas
ni por supuesto lo recoges es que ni te
lo planteas eso que tú estás súper súper
conciencia con la igualdad que le das un
me gusta en el facebook altitude cada
vez que sale alguna actriz de hollywood
pues ahora que te das cuenta a ver si
este año coges el teléfono llamas a tu
madre con tiempo y le dices mamá hay que
hacer alguna cosa
o bien le propones un plato voy a llevar
este año tal
o mejor aún le dices mamá este año lo
hacemos en mi casa me encargo de todo y
vienes a mesa puesta y así el lugar de
llegar a mesa puesta y medio tostado
después de las cañas del día 24
pues realmente haces algo por la
igualdad y no esa concienciación en
redes sociales de compartir tantas fotos
el segundo caso
vives en un país rico haces así en el
grifo milagro sale agua haces clic y se
enciende la bombilla nunca has sufrido
los efectos del cambio climático el mar
en el que pescan vas no está lleno de
plásticos no has tenido que migrar por
un tema relacionado con el clima ni ha
sufrido inundaciones
y qué puedo hacer yo ahora desde segovia
que puedo hacer reduce reutiliza recicla
reduce tu consumo intenta comprar menos
cosas si aún así tienes que comprarlas
intenta comprar cosas que se puedan
reutilizar y déjate del rollo de esos
paquetes de magdalenas hablando un poco
del desayuno que vienen en una bolsa de
plástico dentro del plástico tenemos
cada magdalena dentro de otro plástico y
saco la magdalena y tengo otro plástico
con un papelito para comerme la
magdalena pero además me voy a hacer un
cafelito cojo la cápsula pongo la
cápsula en el café y cada cápsula y cada
cápsula y cada semana y cada mes y cada
persona del norte contaminando y
contaminando y venga a contaminar
por último recicla
me encantan dos bulos que hay sobre
reciclar el primero la excusa perfecta
es que no tengo sitio en la cocina
vamos a ver si te has comprado una
cafetera que hasta te aspira el suelo
como no vas a tener sitio en la cocina
para el cubo de reciclaje pero la mejor
de todas que parece que todas las
personas que no reciclan lo han visto
es que una vez mi vecina del quinto vio
que vacían todos los contenedores de
reciclaje en el mismo camión
venga no seáis cafres y vamos a intentar
hacer las cosas de forma responsable por
último
una de las grandes
maneras de discriminar a la gente es el
lenguaje el lenguaje es representativo
de lo que somos como sociedad
y muchas veces los actos de las
sociedades se reflejan también en el
lenguaje
el 46% de las noticias incluyen
estereotipos racistas o machistas y por
otro lado para que veamos cómo se
corresponde con la sociedad el 49% de
los extranjeros que viven en españa han
dicho sentirse discriminados alguna vez
en su vida
qué hacemos ahora que nos damos cuenta
porque yo estoy en el centro de los
privilegios no hay estereotipos sobre mí
nadie se ríe de mí no existe sobre mí ni
burlas ni mofas corta por lo sano con
las cadenas de whatsapp con los chistes
racistas machistas sexistas homófobos
clasistas di que no
metí un corte a las conversaciones
llenas de estereotipos y por qué no en
lugar de seguir con esas conversaciones
aprovechas el tiempo que vas a ganar
mucho tiempo y hablas con esos
colectivos con esas personas para ver de
verdad cómo entienden el mundo que
piensan cuáles son sus vivencias y
cambias el rollo de
es que nos quitan el trabajo vienen aquí
a robarnos son todas iguales
estos desviados
porque cambiar el mundo es aquí es ahora
y es ya
no valen excusas
es que
y poder y deber hacerlo lo bueno de este
método por lo menos en mi experiencia es
que deja muy buen sabor de boca sin
probar de bocado
alivia el insomnio y el estrés sin tener
que tomar somníferos ves de cerca sin
microscopio y de lejos sin telescopio
por último imaginaos que el último día
de vuestra vida en la tierra os
encontraréis la persona que sois con la
persona que os hubiera gustado ser mi
mayor deseo es que se parezcan muchísimo
o que sean la misma persona mucha suerte
con ello
i
[Música]